kay 218 B was first spotted in 2015
it's an exoplanet meaning it's outside
our solar system it's around a hundred
and eleven light-years away from Earth
to put that in context one light year is
just shy of six trillion miles away it's
what's called a super earth meaning it's
around eight times the mass of our
planet and around double the size it's
so far away researchers haven't actually
been able to see it directly instead
they've examined how starlight has
filtered through the planet's atmosphere
as it orbits around its own star but
what's it actually like well we're not
entirely sure the water content could be
anything from around 0.01% to 50% which
means it could have anything from a very
rocky surface to one primarily covered
by a thick sheet of ice